Some characters are destined to steal the
show.
But when it comes time to cast roles, crazy
things can happen, and it's impossible to
predict who will end up in front of the cameras
when they start rolling.
It may be hard to imagine, but some of your
favorite movies and TV shows almost featured
someone else entirely in the leading role.
Here's a list of roles everyone in Hollywood
wanted to play.
Young Han Solo
Casting the original Han Solo was nearly as
tough as making the kessel run in under 12
parsecs.
So when Lucasfilm and Disney announced they'd
be expanding the Star Wars universe with a
full slate of standalone films — including
a "young Han Solo" prequel directed by Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller — every twentysomething
male actor in the galaxy lined up to audition.
Among the big names: Whiplash's Miles Teller,
Ansel Elgort from The Fault in Our Stars,
Neighbors star Zac Efron, and Brooklyn's Emory
Cohen.
Sources claim over 2,500 actors either met
with casting or submitted tapes before Hail,
Caesar! breakout actor Alden Ehrenreich was
ultimately cast in the hotly anticipated film,
which will fly into theaters in 2018.
Just don't get cocky, kid.
Of course, that wasn't the only Star Wars
role to be hotly contested...
Rey
A long time ago in a galaxy far, far away,
Lucasfilm decided to make a third Star Wars
trilogy and needed a brand new hero to anchor
it.
Director J.J. Abrams and the casting team
launched an extensive search for the right
person to play Rey, the mysterious orphan
at the heart of The Force Awakens.
Oscar nominee Saoirse Ronan auditioned, apparently
having a blast "pretending to take out a lightsaber."
Elizabeth Olsen and Shailene Woodley were
rumored to have auditioned for the part as
well, but Abrams was dead set on casting a
fresh face.
Newcomer Daisy Ridley nabbed the role after
five auditions, including one tearful screen
test that blew Abrams away.
The Force is strong with that one.
Wonder Woman
Hollywood has tried and failed for decades
to bring Wonder Woman to the big screen.
Along the way, quite a few of the film industry's
biggest stars have expressed interest in putting
on her iconic bracelets, including Sandra
Bullock, Mad Men's Christina Hendricks, former
Bond Girl Olga Kurylenko, and even Katie Holmes
— who's no stranger to the DC Comics universe.
When Warner Bros. finally decided to cast
Wonder Woman for 2016's Batman v Superman,
the casting description read:
"Tall, brunette, athletic and exotic."
Israeli actress Gal Gadot won the role — and
a shot at solo cinematic stardom with Wonder
Woman,
James Bond
Betting on who will become the next 007 has
become a national pastime for bookies in the
U.K. Six actors have portrayed the world's
most famous spy on the big screen, but every
time the role is vacated, a new crop of hot
British actors hope to fill Bond's perfectly-tailored
suits.
Among those over the years who've wanted their
martinis shaken and not stirred:
Michael Caine, Liam Neeson, Ralph Fiennes,
Colin Firth, and Clive Owen.
Current Bond Daniel Craig has been hesitant
to confirm his participation in another film
after the success — and stress — of four
films in the role.
Until he does, a few favorite candidates have
emerged as his possible successor: Luther's
Idris Elba, Thor baddie Tom Hiddleston, Tom
Hardy, and Homeland's Damien Lewis.
Even X-Files star Gillian Anderson wants to
put her spin on the role.
Who will be the next secret agent to carry
a license to kill?
Only time will tell.
Christian Grey and Anastasia Steele
When it came time to cast the big-screen adaptation
of erotic bestseller Fifty Shades of Grey,
fans of the series, as well as author E.L.
James, had plenty of opinions regarding who
should play the lead roles.
Fans campaigned especially hard for Matt Bomer,
Alexis Bledel, and Ian Somerhalder, among
others.
James was partial to Shailene Woodley, who
passed because of her commitment to the Divergent
franchise.
Other names entered seriously into the mix:
Oscar winner Alicia Vikander, True Blood's
Alexander Skarsgard, Cara Delevingne, and
Oscar nominee Felicity Jones.
Sons of Anarchy's Charlie Hunnam was originally
cast as Grey opposite Dakota Johnson before
dropping out and being replaced by Irish actor
Jamie Dornan.
Guess Hunnam got too tied up.
Harry Potter
To cast the Boy Who Lived, Warner Bros. put
out an open call on the internet for Harry
Potter lookalikes, and over 40,000 kids sent
in audition materials in hopes of being chosen.
Author J.K.
Rowling's one stipulation was the cast be
British, eliminating Sorcerer's Stone director
Chris Columbus' initial first choice: Stepmom's
Liam Aiken.
But plenty of other young American actors
expressed interest, including the Sixth Sense's
Haley Joel Osment and Jonathan Lipnicki of
Jerry Maguire fame.
Though he wound up playing Draco, even Tom
Felton initially auditioned for the parts
of both Harry and Ron.
Of course, now it's impossible to imagine
anyone but Daniel Radcliffe as the boy wizard.
Clarice Starling
Hannibal Lecter actually never said "Hello
Clarice" in the movie Silence of the Lambs
- really!
And Clarice almost wasn't the Clarice we remember
so well had late director Jonathan Demme had
his way.
Though Jodie Foster campaigned heavily to
get the role, she wasn't anywhere in Demme's
shortlist.
Michelle Pfeiffer was the first choice, having
just worked with Demme on Married to the Mob,
but she was uncomfortable with the movie's
subject matter and ultimately passed.
Meg Ryan was also considered thanks to her
popularity coming off a string of hits, but
she too passed, apparently "offended" Demme
even thought of her for such a gruesome project.
Laura Dern gave such an impressive audition,
Demme said she was "it," but studios weren't
comfortable with the still relatively unknown
actress carrying such a big project.
So he gave the role to Foster — who went
on to win an Oscar.
Katniss Everdeen
After the massive success of the Hunger Games
book trilogy, there was no shortage of actresses
looking to score the highly coveted lead role
of Katniss Everdeen.
Emily Browning, best known for her role in
Sucker Punch and The Uninvited, was a top
contender for the part.
Saoirse Ronan, who starred in Hanna with Cate
Blanchett, was also a strong choice with her
background in hand-to-hand combat and penchant
for athletic roles.
Also on the list were Abigail Breslin from
Little Miss Sunshine and Hailee Steinfeld
of True Grit.
Of course, Katniss went to Jennifer Lawrence,
and the rest was movie history.
Amy Dunne
Anyone who read Gone Girl knows the casting
for the character of Amy Dunne had to be perfect.
This highly sought after part was actively
pursued by Natalie Portman, Charlize Theron,
and Olivia Wilde.
Portman, the Oscar-winning actress best known
for her turn in Black Swan, would have brought
a multi-layered performance, while Charlize
Theron's stunningly disturbed turn as Mary
Ann Lomax in The Devil's Advocate with Keanu
Reeves proved she could have nailed this role
alongside Ben Affleck.
Finally, Olivia Wilde, no stranger to carrying
a film as the deranged Zoe in The Lazarus
Effect, had the looks and the chops for the
role of Amy.
It ultimately went to Rosamund Pike, who turned
out to be the perfect choice.
Vivian Ward
For awhile, it seemed like every actress in
Hollywood was clamoring to play the hooker
with a heart of gold in what many consider
to be Gary Marshall's masterpiece.
Meg Ryan was initially offered the part opposite
Richard Gere, but had to decline the offer
as she had scheduling conflicts.
A string of other actresses nearly took the
opportunity to play Vivian but had concerns
with the subject matter, including Michelle
Pfeiffer and Daryl Hannah.
Julia Roberts ultimately landed the career-making
part.
Michael Corleone
Believe it or not, Paramount Pictures' first
choice for the compelling Godfather franchise
was not Al Pacino.
It's hard not to picture him in the leading
role, but at one point Jack Nicholson was
wanted to play Michael Corleone.
Warren Beatty and Dustin Hoffman also expressed
interest in playing the role and made it far
along in the casting process.
Meanwhile, director Francis Ford Coppola nearly
pulled out of the project as he fought Paramount
executives over casting Marlon Brando as Don
Vito Corleone.
Batman
As far as Batman movies go, Tim Burton's first
Batman flick is legendary.
In the 1980s, every leading man in Hollywood
actively sought an audition to be a part of
what was undoubtedly going to be a hit franchise
with a stellar paycheck.
Can you imagine your favorite Ghostbuster
as Batman?
That's right: Bill Murray was reportedly considered
for the batsuit.
Mel Gibson was rumored too, as were Charlie
Sheen and Alec Baldwin.
After all that, Michael Keaton was the lucky
guy who eventually donned the cape and cowl.
Ferris Bueller
John Hughes reportedly wrote Ferris Bueller's
Day Off with Matthew Broderick in mind, but
other actors had to be considered.
Johnny Depp was initially offered the role
but ultimately turned it down.
Jim Carrey was also rumored to be in the mix,
but after conducting his studio-mandated search,
Hughes returned to Broderick, the guy he'd
wanted for the part all along — and in hindsight,
it's pretty obvious he had the right idea.
Dr. Evil
Who doesn't get a kick out of this super '60s-themed
spy comedy?
Up until a scheduling conflict arose with
the production of Liar, Liar, comedy superstar
Jim Carrey was set to play Dr. Evil in Austin
Powers: International Man of Mystery.
Stuck for an actor to fill the crucial role,
star and creator Mike Myers decided to don
the bald cap and play Austin Powers' nemesis
himself.
Rachel Green
Easily one of the most popular sitcoms of
all time, Friends catapulted every actor involved
to fame, most notably Jennifer Aniston, who
played Rachel Green.
Many young hopefuls auditioned for the role
that would eventually inspire one of the most
imitated hairstyles of all time.
At first, the producers expressed strong interest
in actress Tea Leoni.
But as when Aniston passed on an opportunity
at Saturday Night Live to sign on for the
sitcom, the rest became Must-See TV history.
Scarlett O'Hara
It may very well be the most famous casting
search of all time.
In an effort to build anticipation for the
1939 big screen adaptation of Margaret Mitchell's
epic novel Gone with the Wind, producer David
O. Selznick decided to make his hunt for spunky
heroine Scarlett O'Hara a national obsession.
According to an Entertainment Weekly article,
he had fans writing impassioned letters on
behalf of their favorite actresses and a whistle-stop
tour of the South looking for unknown talent.
TCM.com says that MGM spent two years trying
to cast the role, seeing 1,400 actresses and
testing the likes of Katharine Hepburn, Tallulah
Bankhead, Bette Davis, Paulette Goddard, and
Joan Crawford.
Filming had already begun on the burning of
Atlanta scene when relatively unknown British
actress Vivien Leigh was cast just days before
principal photography was set to begin, ending
a search nearly as melodramatic as Scarlett
herself.
Thanks for watching!
Click The Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!